hello and welcome to this video playing
co-op
okay I'm going for Sicilian again I want
something alright team time on off what
do they do
I cut not g3 that is that so that's a
really I think someone underestimated
line especially under non-professional
level you have them quite a number of
strong players playing this with with
white but you don't don't see it that
much and on the club level Oh on
somewhat somewhat lower levels okay this
is not a great line I think but it's um
it's interesting at least and let's see
what he does some maybe some interesting
points there if he moves the edge pawn
there is some weakness on g3 and with
the bishop coming to c5 so maybe I can
pose him some interesting problems
they're not sure if it is objectively
good but the edge porn pushes them often
quite tricky to meet I wonder if they're
probably not yeah Bishop f4 85 they're
probably not working yeah okay it set
him some problems I had a game before
against this guy was winning with black
knight b3 so what is he doing him Bishop
f4 is what he wants to do I have 95
Daniel it's not the end of the world
yeah I think I can do that age for
trying to be annoying over it just
allows me to open this up I mean it's
it's problem again not not anything
fatal okay Queenie five Queen age five
you know that's it's just not it's just
not going to happen that's a bit too bit
too crude so I don't I don't see my
bishop um getting to c5 or anything it
would be nice but I cannot do it anymore
he has the night on b3 so it's
impossible to get the bishop on to that
diagonal a seven-year I can paint him
that would be great yeah but you don't
get them so now we have an interesting
position it's um it looks like it
Sicilian Raven iam trying I'm trying but
it is a little bit different because
they snow h-bond yeah the age file is
open that has some interesting points
one being that I'm probably not castling
in this game maybe queenside in some
cases but I'm not castling and what is
quite nice about this is that any f4
pushes he has to really consider
carefully because his King will be
weakened tremendously yeah this is this
is an interesting move and I was
thinking I this could be critical even
though I'm not entirely certain what the
point is like after this what is exactly
White's move opening this up must be
interesting yeah
yeah but we're not just going to play
Bishop b7 and then everything here it
takes an awful lot of time for white
I have Bishop d6 if he goes Bishop yam
if he goes with this I can probably play
Bishop to d6 I then rupee six okay so I
have to consider the CAPTCHA because
it's not entirely clear if there is
actually netting all that much I've got
Bishop b5 now that doesn't work it's
made on each one and that doesn't work
at all yeah the H file here is important
hmm yeah Quinn shakes is the simplest
thing to do I'm look up
continues it's a full look
I recently listened listened to a to a
podcast the perpetual chest podcast it's
really nice if you want to have some
high-quality chest interviews go for it
they had a guest on now what was the
first name I don't remember last name
was cobbler I think it was John cobbler
I don't know forgot about it well
interest very interesting character and
don't want to tell the whole story but
one one point of his was that he never
resigned the game ever in his life as he
said and that was think very funny I
mean that never never is really rare
yeah he always placed to mate and says
he has countless games where he won or
drew yeah crazy lost positions anyway
night b3m I mean I don't know what age
five what the best replies the move
looks a little bit dubious for sure but
it's tough the same one thing that I
want to point out is that this is
probably not a good reply I would assume
now something something like that for
example it looks immediately annoying
and I'm threatening Queen go3 and the
night coming to g4 is also going to be
not easy to handle as you see the engine
is not really so much concerned but I
don't have any problem yeah h3 is yeah
and then this one gets interesting I was
thinking about motifs like that if we
this Bishop a7 yeah and that is just not
not so clear maybe white is better here
that's possible and the engine likes
white h5 was a bit of them yeah just go
going for something unconventional let's
say age 4 and he simply
to me let me take and probably that's
not much else so I took him and d6 which
is probably now sensible it's tough to
ever get this out but I think it's a
it's nice to have the age file open him
okay he went with a form and b6 not
strictly necessary but b7 it looks like
a decent enough square and now if I edit
and don't think it works just it just
doesn't work
b5 and oh I should have thought about
this yeah the engine is of course
completely correct in evaluating this
this is just completely winning because
of the H file threatening mate
Luke h1 checkmate and over okay I
thought if that was better
however here I don't have any problems
the rook probably should retreat and
then yeah 95m it's the same idea
whenever that's the capture there's the
meteor on h1 with the rook or queen and
here I can just take the material and be
be winning yeah this this is this would
have been better but I'm just I'm just
an exchange up and still have the
attacking chances so it's um yeah just
just doesn't work and here that with the
main threat it's just entirely over 90
except maybe that says the chick made
already but okay you're woke up so can
take with the Queen
okay guys thanks for watching